They always say there is that moment...
...when you know you're doing what you're supposed to be doing because it's fun.
I wasn't gonna be a teacher.
I was gonna go into business and do all those sorts of things,...
...and I took a history class at James Madison University...
...and I had a professor who inspired me to be a teacher.
Having a teacher who is passionate about her research...
...and her work made me realize that's really what I wanted to do.
The person that made me want to become a teacher was my seventh grade French teacher.
She was very energetic and always came into our class and had just this spark about her...
...that made me want to have the same spark with working with kids.
Two separate teachers inspired me to become a science teacher.
They really geared it to a college level class, and I just found that very engaging.
I think as I matured a little bit,...
...and started to understand what it meant to really be passionate about your work...
...and not just get a paycheck.
To see the change in them, the growth in their thinking,...
...the development in their ability to have conversations and to think deeply...
...has relit the fire that I have as a teacher.
To see that they think back at something that we've done in class...
...has really inspired them to go on to do some kind of career or something.
I think that's a powerful connection I don't think you have...
...if you're a lawyer or a doctor or something like that,...
...and I think it makes the career worth it.